hi i'm kevin o'leary from shark tank you
know me as a discipline investor I'm all
about the cash flow that's why I only
invest in stocks that pay dividends do
you know why because over the last 40
years over 70% of the market's returns
came from dividends not capital
appreciation dividend paying ETFs are
the best choice for my family trusts but
I was challenged to find ETFs that fit
my needs of quality dividend yielding
companies that are diversified that's
key to me find out how I was able to
help my family trust join me for a live
seminar exclusively on ETF tv.com and
dividend comm on August 26 at 11:00 a.m.
I'll be talking about my favorite topic
money and how I'm using a shares ETF to
solve all my trust needs I'll see you
there diversification does not guarantee
a profit or protect against loss before
investing you should carefully consider
the fund's investment objectives risks
charges and expenses this and other
information is in the prospectus a copy
of which may be obtained by visiting the
funds website at wwlp.com entrer ssin in
a particular industry or sector will
subject the funds to loss due to adverse
occurrences that may affect that
industry or sector the fund may use
derivatives which may involve risks
different from or greater than those
associated with more traditional
investments the funds emphasis on
dividend paying stocks involves arrests
as such stocks may fall out of favour
with investors and underperform the
market also a company may reduce or
eliminate its dividend after the funds
purchase of such a company's securities
see the prospectus for specific risks
regarding the fund